[Music]
well thank you
welcome and thank you for for being here
today we are going to
share some positions some interesting
position
our main topic will be about end game
position
some practical endgames i think
it's interesting to see
your skills your knowledge in some
position
so it will be different kind of
position different configuration of
pieces so
let's start with this position try to
find
is why to move and think by yourself um
what is your opinion about this position
what should be the result and then we
can discuss
what do you find about this position is
why to move
he i mean according to to
your calculation try to find is is why
to win
his draw or is black winning in this
point
who want to try you
do you think black is winning yeah okay
because if um
basically like king g2 and white or
black would pick up the f1 and promote
the check so that's why
f5 doesn't work because you're one
square away and if you can e5
then you promote on the same
turn but then queen and one and then
yeah it's a tricky yeah because kindy 5
is
the only way to make draw yes oh you got
the idea but
okay you just maybe
with a little more time you will find it
yeah because
the pawn end games are normally the in
my opinion
it's almost everything about calculation
you know it's
different when there are other in games
with a more pieces that you can have
like some knowledge
some theoretical position that you know
before
and but opponent games are normally
about
a calculation and this is a one
practical case right that only can d5
a make drawing do you
get the idea or not no because
king e5
as he mentioned at the end a king g2
and there is a race but
when blood promotes f1 h8 there is queen
a1 right and blood
win the queen and if a king f5
is the same but the problem is that when
blood promotes f1 queens is with checks
and the white pawn will be in a7 right
so for that reason king d5 and of course
blood cannot take because king e4
and why this one on time right okay
okay it's white to move here
again trying to find try to fight
to find is if white can win or is a draw
this position
and again i think that by calculating
you can find the
the right idea it's just about
calculation this position
i i don't think it's too hard but if you
calculate you can
find it
want to try
do not but what do you think is
winning or it's a draw
king f1 okay um go
k5
king d4
king one king d3
um no but i i'm going to try no
i i take only 4 on b5 king e5
want to try or well i mean
i don't see a way to win
but i'm also not that good
yeah the point is and you you see
something
yes yes this is the idea to get the same
position but
it's black to move is lost
d5 and
unkind d4 or k3 and k4 that's the
problem
because if blood go for example king
c3 just f4 right okay
suppose you're starting f1 kindy 5
king g2 kindy 4 kinji 1
kindy 5 king f1
kindy 4 and king e2 right
you got it because if blood make any
other
move like for example kinsey phi again
f4 right or king e5
b4 yeah and king d4
then f4 is the way right
can see four and five and yeah it's the
only way to to win
okay let's do the move king f1
okay now blood should go
kindy 3 or king d5
suppose that king d3
you go king g2
now again there is not a king c3
loss for f4 and k3b4
that should keep the position king a
d4 and now kg1
king d5 or d3
king f1
and now the problem okay to finish kindy
five
king e3
yeah because king a e5 now f4
kinsey phi f i mean f4 is coming now
for example king e5 f4
king f5 king f3 right
and there is no tying with the g2 or
nothing
and then before king d5 for example
before
cutting okay it's fine if you have any
question
in any position i will stop it okay i
just maybe it was too fast
okay sorry
um okay
this is a interesting position it's a
very famous one
maybe some of you know and it's
quite to move and there is
you know this position or not yeah
if you know it's okay
are you do you want to try
some idea for for why
yeah the problem with rook
a5 is like blood can go g6
um
yes or even i think h4 through h5
and g5 maybe it's more precise
yes maybe this one is a tricky one the
idea is to start with
a king h7 right
because king g7 doesn't work after
h4 and the difference is after h4
king g6 h3 kg5
h2 king g4
and if blood just promote here h1
kg3
yeah and without the bone this bone on
g7
there will be queen hj right stopping
rook e1 a1 and it's completely
different
blood can promote knight here for
example
but after king f3 is winning completely
right
for g6 g 5
check king 2
takes knight f2 one king
okay
okay this one is white to move
try to find if you can win this as white
you ready
sorry
bishop f1
well but how can you continue after
after
king f3 for example
yeah you need to take care because you
know if the king goes to the
h5 or g5 your pawn promote in the wrong
right because bishop f1 king f3
king g4 is coming and you cannot prevent
this right
so now i'll guess bishop
but you can calculate okay just so
because it's first if you wing wing or
if draw draw
for example after bishop g4 how can
blood continue
and then
because you need to avoid or at least to
to win
even if black does this many over
because
blood wanted to go king e3 king e4 king
e5
king f6 king 7 and king h8 right
bishop g4 king e3 h4 king e4
h5 king e5
actually there is an easy way for black
if you go bishop g4
i go king e3 h4 king f4
yes winning a temple right
attacking the bishop if h5 king g5
if you move your bishop king e5 and king
f6
no any other idea or
it's a tricky one it's okay it's a
bishop move
of course it's the only way but
you have to find some idea where to put
exactly the bishop
can you find the idea after bishop d7
for example
how come you win after king e3
h4 king e4 h5
king a5 a6
king f6 and now
i feel like i've seen something
and doesn't win right this way because
king f7 bishop h7
king f6
no but h6 king f6 and bishop ea
is the idea
to put the bishop
okay bishop d7
well it's the only move the only way to
win
of course now now king f3 is easy
because
h4 and king f4 can deform
right this is force h4
king e4
h5 king e5
yeah this is the only square where the
bishop can
do the the worldwide which will be
too hard or maybe possible to find
it's tricky though
okay let's continue
okay it's why to move try to
see if you can win this or it's a draw
or
well it's it's a it's winning for a
while i will advance this
but there is only one way to to win this
position
yes want to try
sorry knight b3 and
kim b4
okay if you play knight b3 i go
a5
yeah it's the idea you can bring the
king and put
but yeah first knight b3 and
put the knight on a1
um
go here here
and there is no time because even when
is blood go
to with well a3 is there is nice c2
right
and there is not a
you got the idea or not if they play a3
eventually
yes well it depends in which position
right because
for example starting with this move a5
or
suppose that i go here a3
king is seven
now a3 i'd say
right and i see two i protect
in kim before king
and now a3 well nice e2 right again
b3 a2 well maybe i'm not sure because
there is the
c3 and king
but yes it's a interesting good
point that knight b3 and put the knight
on a1 is
the only way
okay how about this one
if you knew the first that the similar
in this game maybe you know this one too
because it's kind of
um
you wanted to try i i can't
calculate it well so i have either one
move off or i have it
how about you uh i
i mean i have an idea but i also can't
uh calculate this anymore and you
i think i know the move but i don't see
the variation
i think it's root g5 so that he has g6
on you uh
both of you were thinking about rook g6
yeah and i was thinking g3
to let him make
yeah well it's this is a concrete
evaluation
basically you have to start to of course
to sing
thing about rook g7 took g6 shook g5 or
k6
right there are not or any other rook g7
is more or less clear that
doesn't work so you have
kim b6 or starting with rook g5 or
g6 yes i i my first
thought was to confirm that there is
only one
one move right which is rook g5
it's important to give this time to play
g6 for black because
if you will immediately i mean first
king b6 there is g5
that's the point and group g5 and then
king h2on
is a draw
if kim b6 g5 is
because kings king h2 king rook g5 still
is
trampoled some the main variation but if
you start
again rook g6 for example king h2
right kim b6 h3 king c5 king h1
king d4 h2
and now what to do because it's slay
made
so you need to to remove and the the
problem is or
the idea that with the you're right king
on
d4 but your rook on on g5
the blood can go g6 that is not a
slide made right then after g6
rook g3 g5 king
okay let's make the move okay
here you you saw the whole variation or
not
but tell me until
everything is this is more or less force
right
here here
okay now king
e3 g6 right
um this is what you see right on
rook g3 g5
king f2 g4 reveal
now takes right
yeah everything was so i mean if you got
the
idea the right idea rook g5 i think you
can find
you now you got the idea well
but i don't know why
okay let's try
to see the difference right
iii now doesn't work now
like this
well but good point anyway yeah
king somewhere g4
yeah it's fourth right g5 and g4
okay
okay this one is black to move
try to think and what is your opinion is
this is a draw is winning for
for white
i need to draw
um okay which is a
uh
bishop d5
okay okay
let me this one
do you know the concept in this kind of
position when
there is a bishop with different colors
and two pawns in the center for example
which is the best way to put the pieces
or not
in order
normally suppose that as blood
in order to understand what is black
trying to
to achieve you need to get your king for
example
in front of one of the pawn in e6 and
the bishop is stopping d5
but in b7 right is the best way
to to get draw this position
in general right because in this way
you are stopping d5 and white king
cannot move to c5
but yeah in this position is is for
example it's important to start with b
chop c4
mhm
for example if bishop b5 bishop before
and
is winning but it's
okay after bishop c4
check
keen c6
i'm not king e6 because kindly 2 on king
c3
and the king khan goes to to c5
mm-hmm
the easiest way is to go here bishop a7
let um fold this one
just here here
and the bishop on f7
yeah you need to stop e6 but at the same
time
attack one of the bomb okay
okay is now is why to move and try to
think if
rook c7 was here for
for white if this is wing
winning or not after rook c7
do you think he's winning
and do you see any way to defense the
the position
for for black after this
normally when we started this kind of
end game position
it's it's tricky because we we tend to
think that this
very simple no different colors but
there are
many tricky positions that this
important to know right and the stronger
side normally has to to
have at least one or two pounds pass
and many times even with two pawn down
it's a draw we have a good very good
chance and for example this position is
very interesting
at the rook c7 is a mistake because this
is technical
winning position but why just king of
two one king three the trick is after
rooks is seven
black takes takes
and now b4
you got the idea
after takes eight a b4
now
how can black
yes
well apparently there is still some
chunks for white but not
is is not enough right after queen king
f2
takes king e3 okay this is like a
best practical chance but it's not
enough
check king f7
um
yeah apparently there is no way that
blood can win this
king d4 k96 right
the a2 pawn is the key to to save the
the game
okay let's check another position
differing position
do you know this position
thank you
sorry
well this is like a the key position
when of course is winning for the white
versus rule but the
the idea is to get this if black to move
here is
his he will lost the rook so you have to
get the same position
um that but that
i mean you let the blood play right this
is the the idea to get the
this position in order to to win in some
practical
games for example if the
the strongest the the weakest side know
how to
to defend and you don't know that this
is like
the the winning position it can be hard
so to win right
but if you know this that this is the
the key position to to get
then will be easy
let's see the money over how to now you
start queen e5
king 87 king e1
and yeah
now because now black
should put fart from the king the rook
and this is the idea
to get the separate rook
from the the king position for black so
you can win the the rope for example
here
yeah because kim queen b1 right
and
group for example b1 and then you have
to put
you get your queen to a7
and for that okay that was weight
this
yeah for example this position suppose
that is a kind of position in
the king in the center but the idea is
to get the winning position
i mean to bring blood king to the center
i mean now blood can put the rook far
from the king but
it's not possible to to take you okay if
you if blood
put the roof in the right place for
example like this so if
you if you need in order to win you need
to
to bring the blood king to the corner of
course
and bring yourself know your own king
for the winning position to f3
then now the the the maneuver
in order to to understand what he wanted
to to get
is that you need to to put your queens
your own queens
far from your king at some point
stopping some checks
to the background check
yeah for example now the king is getting
close
and there is no check on on ea
for black
i mean this position is in order to to
you have just
have to to get the idea right and maybe
you can practice later but if you
understand
the key concept i think won't be
difficult to
to get the
queen h5 yeah sometimes it's
most important to to take some squares
you know to give to put the blood sides
like a suction
and not give a lot of check like this
for example
can you one queen d5
um now for example you need to
here and this is the the winning
position to say
and again you got the the winning
position
so you got the the idea more or less
about this
okay let's see another example
um
well this position i just wanted to show
on
some concept in knight's endgame
position that is similar to the pawn and
games
normally this the side who has the the
far farthest pawn pass
has the chance to to win right and for
example
here the h pawn is very strong for black
and this is another
key concept to understanding this kind
of knight a
again right here bloody wind like this
and this is
this one is the same right that white
has the if
the a bomb pass and is still winning
okay
okay this this position is in in order
to chose
that this kind of in-game position is
typical
then in general by concept when you have
bishop against knight and there is spawn
in both side of the ball normally the
the bishop is a
stronger right in general and
for example here it's uh obvious that
even for blood the pawn construction is
better so
this kind of position is quite typical
after e5 which is the stronger move
it's clear that for example these two
pawn especially the c5
pawn stopping no b3 a4 c4 is a very bad
structure so it should be winning for
for black disposition
g5 is a is a wind missile
now is on for for a while
so black king will enter
um and this one who know this one
if no you
do you okay
know the how to win or is a draw
i'm guessing g5 works at some point but
i don't see that variation
yes in this configuration where there is
three again three
group games this bishop which is
stopping the blood king to enter right
there's only one way
to win yeah it's do you know this one or
not
okay it's but this is it possible to get
it
in i i i actually i got this
again and some games you see one of the
position that is possible to get it in
one game
yeah now is you have to prepare g5 as
black
but you need to put your rook first on
d6
in the in the third round so it's
important this
detail in order to to win
i mean this is the only way to to win
the position
okay we can bishop cc from d2
now g5
so why can't i with both pawn but
actually
h4 king
yeah because that you see the idea is to
stop g6
to put the rook on d6
king h2 takes takes
rook d4
takes
okay after g5
play with ff4 takes takes
king f2 check
hmm
hmm
this one you know
yeah apparently in this position um
group against bishop when even with the
h i mean without this pawn is draw
when you know when you have your king in
different color in the corner right of
your bishop
this one is more or less clear and
but with the h pawn if the pawn is on h5
here like here for example a white
cannot win
and with a pawn on h4 this is winning
this
position
again this is a something to to remember
because idea with the penguin h4
is that who i need to get king h5
and king g4
to win right because for example if you
play like a white you play go for
example king g5 and a6
even with this pawn in h6 and the bishop
controlling h7 you cannot win this
position right
for example check king f5
rook g6 and from g3
piece of c2 that this position etc
you can go a6 but you cannot win this
now yeah bishop to g6
yeah because the if you
for example you have the pong on h4 let
me see if i have it here
you i hope that i have it you need to go
rook g7 rook g5 and then at some point
you need to go but
we you with your king right king
h5 and king g4 okay let me i hope i
i have it and we finish with okay
this one
this one okay
so
and this is lost because the king is in
the wrong
side right
you have the same color you know that or
not
if it's not clear just let me know uh i
don't know
yeah okay for example in bishop g1
yeah because you blood need to avoid the
attack the the bishop
bishop h2 rook h1
bishop g3 rook h3
now bishop f4 rook c3 visual f2 rook a3
so we you will take the visual bishop d6
here and here
after this there is no right
okay let me see if i have no
no i don't think i have it in this file
but is it's a
okay you can try to find it yeah and you
will compare and it's
interesting to to check it the
difference right
yeah because when your pawns on h5 yeah
if in the fifth round you cannot win
yeah okay
okay i think this is that's it
i hope that you learned something you
enjoyed i
try to pick some different kind of
position
being to make some like it's summarizing
one hour and
some practical advice and tool for you
in order to grow as your you know your
skilling
and knowledge in the end game position
okay
thank you and i hope that you
will improve with that
[Music]
you